so according to the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention one in four US
adults live with a disability among
younger adults we're talking students
here included cognitive disability is
most prevalent for the others it would
be mobility disability but if you think
about it you know virtually every single
one of us can expect to experience some
form of disability in our lifetime and
yet in our society and in the society
disease around the world we have still a
lot of widespread misunderstandings
misperceptions and stigma associated
with disability and those who live with
disability
I'm Henry Cohn from the Yale alumni
association I'm delighted to welcome all
of you to our panel discussion today
entitled diversability addressing
disability equity inclusion at Yale and
beyond this program is part of a series
events taking place on campus and off
this month in observance of National
Disability Awareness Month this
particular program is collaboration
between the Alumni Association the
office of diversity inclusion and
diversity at Yale which is a fini group
on campus for staff with disabilities I
want to take this opportunity actually
thank a few people who helped make this
program possible
first is melody Norton who's co-chair
for DES Melanie we also have Deborah
Stanley McAuley who's the senior
diversity officer on campus I don't see
her but I want to thank her nonetheless
and last but not lease Miranda mon fils
de of the Office of Diversity inclusion
who actually took care of most of
logistics here so we hope that you will
find this discussion informative in
looma dating and and even perhaps
inspirational but we're certainly
delighted to bring you this lineup of
speakers that we have here so please
join me in a warm round of applause for
our speakers
[Music]
thank you so much good afternoon
everybody my name is Jan allure Stein I
am Yale class of 78 Sabra college
anybody here from Saybrook shut it out
really seriously I'm from the best
residential college at Yale Sabra
College and it is really wonderful to be
home my background is as an attorney I'm
retired from practice I'm also a
disability rights advocate and a member
of the disability community as you
probably have guessed from the presence
of the one who is undisputedly the most
adorable in the room my guy dog Shiloh
who is at my feet my disability is
blindness and I have the privilege of
being moderator here today so we're
going to do a little bit of tactile
interaction when we get to the Q&A
session please just roll with me this is
going to work out just fine I had the
privilege of serving two terms in the
Obama administration on the National
Council of disability serving as the
senior disability policy advisor to the
Hillary for America campaign and I
currently am the vice chair finance for
the DNC disability Council as well as a
member of the National Board of the
foundation Fighting Blindness and a
member of the National Academy of
Sciences engineering and medicine forum
on aging and disability well do some
ground rules as soon as we've got
everybody introduced and I'm just so
delighted you could be with us today
hi I'm dr. Sarah Poggi I'm here in two
capacities I'll start with the
professional one I'm a graduate of the
Yale School of Medicine class of 1996
and I'm a high-risk obstetrician I take
care of pregnant women with
complications medical complications but
also genetic complications
I do ultrasound and maybe diagnose
babies with problems and also in a
consultative role I do medical
malpractice expert witness work on cases
where a child may have been born with
complications that are leading to
lifelong disabilities however the reason
I am here is more for a personal reason
my medical school classmate dr. Matt
Poggi and I married in 1995 and two
years later he was diagnosed with
multiple sclerosis he ultimately became
quadriplegic and from see one down so he
was unable to feed himself really do any
anything except his cognition was
excellent and he died about six months
ago so I'm here to speak I guess as a
caretaker talked about how it was
raising our two daughters and that home
and I actually really happy to say I
have a daughter who's here now and she
is in saber okay
to your point and I'm going to end by
saying how I got on Henry's radar there
was a veteran's Yale veterans event in
Washington DC and my husband was a navy
doctor he did not step on a bomb in
Fallujah but he was a quadriplegic
veteran and he wanted to go to the event
and like any good caretaker my first
question was is it accessible and Henry
found out that unfortunately there for
veterans was on the second floor of an
inaccessible building and I just
expressed concern and maybe I was a
little firm but I want to credit Henry
with coming back in spades by saying wow
you know we need to do better for our
our alumni that are disabled in the
community as a whole
thank you good morning my name is Jim
Conroy I'm here from Pennsylvania and I
was here from 66 to 70 in silliman
college I studied brain research
physiological psychology my life got
formed right after graduation my first
job was a study for a consulting firm on
the impact of a brand new law the
Developmental Disabilities Act of 1970
and my first task was to draw a sample
of facilities nationwide to study what
would happen as a result of this new law
and drawing purely at random the first
place to visit
I drew a place called Pennhurst state
school in hospital which is one of the
most notorious institutions for people
with intellectual and developmental
disabilities in the world now and going
there changed my life I was in the midst
of the women's movement the anti-war
movement I was on a stage on May Day in
1970 I was in the thick of it but when I
saw this these inhumane conditions I
knew something had to be done I've spent
my old life since then trying to figure
out what to do but my role was simply
scientist so I thought maybe somebody
who studied the human brain could be
useful in this field
and I went to Pennhurst and found that
there's a lot to do in 1998 I went to
Los Angeles to visit college friends and
we decided to go see the Holocaust
Center in which the first place I knew
of that hands you an identity card and
you go through not knowing whether you
lived or died in the Holocaust until the
end three weeks later I woke up back in
Philadelphia in the middle of the night
saying the disability rights movement
means a place like that a place where
we'll never forget where people can go
by the millions and learn what's been
happening and I'm gonna try to convince
everybody for the rest of my life
probably that we need a place of memory
and learning in Washington there are
four great civil rights museums one is
in progress but there are three that are
there in the mall now and we'll be
working for a fifth the fort well
there's that the Holocaust Memorial
Museum national and the the National the
American Museum Museum of the American
Indian the National Museum of American
get african-american history and culture
and the fourth is in progress the
National Women's History Museum which
was a commission was set up in 2014 the
fifth will be unnamed the National
Center or American Museum and Disability
Rights in history and every disability
group will have to be represented it's
going to take an easy ten years but
it'll be a good ten years that are going
to thank you my name is Sarah Scott I am
the director of student accessibility
services here at Yale where the office
that works with all students at the
University that register with us and
identify as having a disability I am NOT
a yellow alum but I'm a Jonathan Edwards
fellow which helps for something
my background is as an attorney but I've
spent most of my career working and
disability issues in higher ed we work
with students in all issues of
accessibility here on campus issues
related to academic accommodations to
ensure that students can access their
courses and their materials and their
handouts and readings and powerpoints in
an accessible way we work around issues
of Housing and physical accessibility of
the campus infrastructure which in the
campus this old can be a challenging
task sometimes we work on issues around
transportation and dining and and
there's really no edge there's no
boundary to what we do if we have a
student that has an accessibility
concern we just do a lot of creative
problem-solving to try to find a way to
meet that sometimes we're very
successful and sometimes we're still
working on it and I'm very honored to be
here on this panel with such great
speakers I'm Paige Lawrence I'm betoken
undergrad on this panel I'm the
president of defy which is disability
empowerment for Yale a student advocacy
group and I run the disability peer
mentor program which is in its third
year we now have 32 mentees we just got
our latest addition and we have 11
mentors so the program continues to grow
throughout the semester and I oversee
all the matching of mentors and mentees
as défi president we you know work to
advocate for the disabled community on
campus we have events to build community
we do advocacy and awareness work we've
worked quite a bit with DES and I also
want to say on behalf of the students we
really appreciate what student
accessibility services does and how hard
Sarah works for all of us so about
myself and not so much about the
disability groups I am in Harper College
formerly known as Calhoun
so not favorite yay and I'm a history
and Near Eastern languages and
civilizations double major studying
Egyptology in the ladder
I plan to study the history of
disabilities although we don't have a
separate disability studies program so I
am sitting disabilities in the context
of different ancient civilizations and
pre-modern civilizations
I personally got involved with this
because in my senior year of high school
I was diagnosed with an immunodeficiency
which is a type of invisible illness or
chronic disability and as a results you
know I've had to navigate the
bureaucracy of Yale Health getting
approved for infusions my freshman year
of college
now I receive monthly infusions and I
have to navigate you know my class
schedule around my infusion schedule and
it has really changed my life and my
perspective on you know how to stay
organized how to deal with different
challenges as they arise it's totally
changed my perspective and as a result I
became very involved with the disability
community on campus thank you everybody
so as I stated previously it is my great
privilege to be the moderator of the
panel this morning so we're going to set
a couple of ground rules first of all
even though I am here to gently guide
the discussion we want to make sure that
everybody's opinions are heard and so
we're going to reserve some time for
questions and comments at the end of the
session today and we encourage everyone
to keep track of what they would like to
say so that we have an opportunity to be
sure that every one of the room is heard
secondly it is part of my responsibility
as monitor to be the time police and
because we have so much to discuss in
this very broad talk topic of disability
identity inclusion and accessibility
both in terms of here at Yale and and
throughout the nation we are going to
keep to some pretty strict time limits
if an answer from anybody in the room
goes to more than three or four minutes
you will probably see me rise and gently
stand next to you or behind your chair
that's the first hint the second hint is
likely going to be a little tap on your
shoulder hopefully I'll be able to find
it but here's the kicker if you do not
desist then the final element is on
secret signal to my four-legged
assistants here
Shilo is gonna kiss you all over your
face until you stop so with that said
and the ground roll set we have really a
lot to discuss and we're going to
dispense with the urban legend of age
before beauty and go right to our
current undergraduate student page thank
you for being with us and I'm wondering
if you would open the discussion with us
by just talking a little bit about what
you found the most surprising thing good
and bad when you entered Yale as a
student with a disability thank you so I
want to start off by saying that when I
was a first-year so I'm currently a
junior when I was a first year I was
still navigating the diagnosis process
coming to terms with the fact that I was
now disabled this was lifelong I would
have to receive treatment for the rest
of my life it's not something that would
just go away or be a temporary obstacle
and for the first year I was sort of in
denial that this was a part of my life I
wasn't involved with the disability
community at all but then my sophomore
year I signed up for the peer mentor
program and I found a lot of individuals
who you know like me have struggled with
this new identity of being disabled or
having a disability on this campus and
who have faced different challenges and
I very quickly started learning about
the other types of disabilities on
campus and how hidden or visible they
are and how accessible this campus is or
sometimes the lack thereof of
accessibility you know how hard student
accessibility services work what the
accommodations are in fact I just
learned last week that there is a new
accommodation I could have taken
advantage of when I was concussed last
year so there are all sorts of resources
and I think what surprised me the most
was how decentralized the community and
the resources here are and how hard it
is to navigate especially when you
weren't born with a disability because
for some of my peers who are born with
their disabilities they've navigated
their whole life it's second nature it's
not this new additional challenge
whereas for me it was just a whole new
world of figuring out how it affected me
personally and figuring out
now the leader on this campus at the
same time so I found that the
decentralization of resources was the
most surprising thing on this campus but
then the most positive surprise was how
strong the community of disabled
students here is through groups like
define the peer mentor group I had a
fantastic peer mentor my sophomore year
I she's still one my best friend she
graduated last year and she's the one
who started the peer mentorship program
just over two and a half years ago now
and the the bond that we built over the
shared experience of having a chronic
illness and being disabled on this
campus is so strong one of the strongest
bonds I think you can form is having the
shared experience of being a disabled
student on this campus even if your
disability is wildly different it is
still such a unifying experience so I
was pleasantly surprised by the strength
of the community and the passion of the
students that I've been involved with on
this campus thank you so Sarah Scott
Chang that kind of leads us into a lot
of directions in terms of your very
important role in assisting students at
Yale with disabilities and also
interacting with faculty and staff some
of whom also are dealing with the
challenges of disability we heard talk
about the diffuse element of the
disability community that's something
that that permeates disability community
nationally and we also heard a little
talk about the accessibility issues that
are certainly profound when you're
trying to fully integrate students with
disabilities so could you tell us a
little bit about what your life has been
like assuming the mantle of the head of
this very important department at Yale
and what you have viewed as some of your
biggest challenges and successes I think
worked really hard to increase our
efficiency and increase the
accessibility for students we just
recently changed our name
month ago from resource office on
disabilities to student accessibility
services and we have had overwhelmingly
positive feedback on that and I think
that that goes a long way toward
increasing the visibility of our office
to students that maybe we're not born
with a disability and are kind of new to
their diagnosis also students with
mental health conditions that don't the
word disability doesn't really resonate
with them and it more accurately defines
the work that we do we work to create
accessibility and that's been a really
good change
weaving increased a lot of our internal
efficiency in ways that students very
much appreciate kind of brought our
practices up to date so students don't
have to come physically pick up papers
from us every semester and then
physically take them to their faculty
we've gone digital and paperless and
that's been I think a really good change
for students some of the challenges that
we see is I think Yale has a culture of
perfection almost where everyone is
expected to be perfect in the thing that
they do and there's not a lot of grace
allowed for people who are not perfect
for people who are struggling for people
who are still trying to learn something
and that affects the the community of
students with disabilities because there
is the stigma that if you have a
disability that's a weakness that's a
deficiency and I wholeheartedly do not
believe that but a lot of people do even
students with disabilities have kind of
internalized that idea so I think that
there's a lot of room for the campus to
grow and and just be a little bit more
progressive in terms of what disability
means the people who say my disability
is my superpower I think there's a lot
of value there
and just understanding that people learn
in really different ways that taking an
exam that's 80 multiple choice questions
and that being the only grade for a
course might not be the best way to
evaluate a student's knowledge of
material every time and just kind of
allowing people to understand that
students can look a lot of different
ways and if it doesn't look the way you
are or the way that you expect that
doesn't mean that it's necessarily bad
or worse or a week or less it's just
different and that's okay so thank you
so much for that comment and we're
already starting to see a couple of
themes emerge here in terms of the fact
that identity in the disability
community is something that is unique to
every person with a disability but also
in terms of the kinds of expectations
and supports and now the first
discussion of stigma I'm gonna skip
right over you Jim for just one second
because stigma has been raised as an
issue by Sarah to our author Sarah this
is I think a rare privilege on a panel
for us to have someone who has sat with
this really many many hats and vistas
into the various elements of the
disability community both as a family
member who has been so recently involved
in the end-of-life process and I'm sure
everyone here agrees with me and sending
condolences to you and your family for
your recent loss also as a physician who
sees the side of diagnosis and treatment
in this case women with disabilities and
we're over and I want to get to this
with my question a member of the
caregiving and supporter network that
that surrounds people with disabilities
if they're fortunate enough to have
families so we know 61 million Americans
are challenged by disabilities but that
number grows exponentially if you
consider the family members who are
caregivers and loved ones and supporters
and all of the work that they do that is
usually largely uncompensated and hardly
ever recognized so Sarah could you talk
to us a little bit about what your
perspective is is
part of this kind of shadowy existence
behind the disability community I'll say
I was bone tired for the four years that
he was quadriplegic I was the medical
director of my unit at work I did not
miss a single day of work because my
income mattered terribly to pay for his
care and we had basically I was then the
medical director of a nursing home for
one person at home and he was taking up
to 35 pills a day
I had six aides you know all sorts of
durable medical goods that I was having
to keep track of you know things he was
admitted to the hospital I think 29
times in four years 11 surgeries
including an amputation of his left leg
because of a pressure sore because we
couldn't get aids and during a blizzard
it was just it was a lot and at the same
time I have two girls that are when was
in seventh grade when he became
quadriplegic the other ninth grade the
girl who's now at Yale but I became a
single parent for them he was of course
present to them and they would watch TV
or do you know do things like this
together but they say mom we were down
to half a parent because we lost dad and
you spent so much time with him that we
didn't have much of you so I have some
guilt right now because like I wouldn't
have been able to come up and do this if
he were alive I mean there's an irony in
all of this because I always had to have
you care for him set up
I just know them because we had had his
diagnosis of MS early and we were both
physicians we had healthy incomes and we
saved so we were ready for our rainy day
it came earlier than we expected but we
we could do it and I just fear for the
people out there that doesn't have the
resources that we did to navigate the
healthcare system and have a nest egg to
go into because we weren't bankrupt by I
mean we definitely took a hit I have I
don't know if any of you have had
someone like this in the home but I have
guilt because I would get frustrated I
would work all day
come home you'll have to cook dinner or
feed them with my hands and and
sometimes I would I wasn't the nicest
and I have a lot of guilt about that I
I'm trying to think what else to say I
just didn't really proud I never put him
in a nursing home though I'm so proud of
that so that's maybe the best point for
us to jump off and talk about what Jim
has witnessed in his many years working
with the disability community and also
his aspiration to make sure that there
is Institute of learning where people
can come to understand the disability
community we have already heard many of
the major words that are associated with
our community inclusion accessibility
support caregiving frustration guilt so
assuming that we get this civil rights
museum up and going in or around
Washington DC what is the message that
you would like this institution to send
to people who are not as engaged as we
are in the disability community oh it's
it's education it's learning it's people
don't understand they don't know they
don't know the history of disabilities
they don't know the pain of exclusion
and I think if we had a place like the
National Museum of african-american
history and culture where millions of
people come through it's the most
record-breaking thing and as you said 61
million Americans with disabilities and
their families this museum would be a
big step in learning to accept and
include and that's the number-one
message is not just learning it's actual
action which is what the NMA is HC does
it's it's not just learning about
history it's taking action of changing
attitudes so you used one of my favorite
words which is action I'm sure everybody
who has been part of the Yale experience
and particularly those of us who were
students here at Yale have some
significant memory of that aha moment
where a teacher really got through to us
with words that have stayed with us
their whole lives so you just mentioned
when I was fortunate enough to be a
history student here at Yale and my
senior advisor was John Morton blammo
who is one of the iconic
history professors and in our first
meeting when I went shaking with fear to
talk to him about my proposal for my
senior thesis project
he sat me down and he said I don't care
what your write about I don't care how
much you research you need to understand
that I will not tell or tolerate
anything that is not in the active tense
no passivity no past tense
no subjunctives forget those rules I
only want to hear from you in the act of
tense and I think that's what you're
talking about Jim so a number of years
ago gonna go back to Sarah Scott Chang
over there
Yale made a remarkable statement in
announcing that they were going to go
completely digital in order to step
towards full inclusion for the yellow
institution and for their extended
community and they are now requiring
that not only everything on campus but
all of the vendors make all of their
information available in digital fashion
this is good news for someone like me
who is blind but Sarah I wonder if you
could help us understand what that means
in terms of Yale taking on a leadership
role and how that transition is going
currently we have some of our digital
accessibility folks in the room Mike
Vaughn and Michelle Morgan the CTL does
a lot of things working around
accessibility and they've been really
amazing partners we work with students
for course materials we work directly
with faculty so that they can remediate
things on their end this can be people
who have been blind throughout their
life and rely on a screen reader like
jaws that reads everything they see on
their screen it can also include
students who just got a concussion and
and have an intolerance for looking at
screens for the next three weeks and
suddenly they're able to listen to their
readings instead of visually scan
on their laptop and it's been really
really amazing I've heard from a number
of outside of the community people
vendors and and just other people that
that use different parts of Yale that
that the push toward digital
accessibility has been really helpful on
there and in being able to access
materials but also in modeling that kind
of best practice behavior so along the
lines of best practice page I just want
to know how that best practice
philosophy feels to you as a person
who's engaged as a student and I know
that the digital element is not so much
associated with your personal experience
as a student at Yale but can you talk to
us a little bit about what the
disability culture is here at Yale and
how you feel inclusion and integration
exist or is is coming along for the
disability community of students that's
a big question that we've been working
on lately how do create this community
at Yale of students with disabilities
and how to make it more inclusive so
we've taken certain steps like becoming
affiliated with cultural centers on
campus
we just affiliated with the
asian-american Cultural Center on campus
because we're trying to be more
intersectional in our outreach we've
worked with other student groups that
are not disability related inherently
but that do intersects with disability
we've worked with different faculty
groups we've been reaching out to grad
students and working more with the
Graduate groups and helping foster
graduate groups as well and overall
we're just trying to get everyone
involved in this community in the same
room because we've been so fragmented
empirically that getting everyone in the
same space on the same page even just in
contact has been huge this year a new
Divinity School group is forming
currently a new graduate group is
hopefully coming soon there there are a
lot of new groups
you know on the rise and working with
defying the disability peer mentor
program and we're also trying to create
you know longevity for our groups a
lasting impact that will last even after
I've graduated
you know the founder of the peer mentor
program recently graduated and handed it
off to me and we want to make sure that
there continue being these transitions
and that these programs don't just die
off once we graduate we want there to be
institutional memory as well and you
know another way that we're working
together as a community is that we
pooled our collective experiences at
Yale and created a resource guide to
disability at Yale it is a 26 page
document viewable online and for anyone
who wants the link I can give it to you
it's just tinyurl.com slash disability
at Yale and it's this complete resource
using all of our experiences with
different types of disabilities to help
others in our community understand what
exists and what communities exists on
this campus it includes a section about
different student groups that are
involved with disability there's you
know a club that does ASL now there's
all these different smaller groups that
are tangentially involved in the
community and help build and grow the
network and outreach that we have so we
worked very hard to reach a larger
portion of the student body and I think
the peer mentor program is the single
best way in which we've expanded our
outreach and you know last year we had
20 some mentors by the end of the year
this year we're in the 30s and still
growing our mentees and we're still
growing and I think that that alone just
says a lot about how more people are
getting involved in the community more
people want to be involved in the
community and I will say also on the
peer mentor forums when you fill out a
form to request a mentor there's a
question that asks how much do each
these things matter to you and one of
them is connection with resources one of
them is mentorship and one of the
options is connection with the broader
community of students with disabilities
at Yale most of the mentees when they
fill out that form say that that matters
the most to them
connection with the broader community
here at Yale so it's clear that students
here want to be connected with other
students who like them have gone through
the experience of being disabled at Yale
and people want to be a part of a larger
network here at Yale so we're working on
building that Network the best we can
because it's clear that students want to
be a part of this network and want to be
involved in these you know subgroups and
this larger community so we're doing
everything we can to make this a reality
it certainly sounds like you are so I
just want to do one quick follow up
question here it will count into your
rebuttal time don't worry
you talked about doing things the best
you can and it certainly sounds like
they engaged effort from the side of the
students who are within the disability
community is beyond anything I think
that I could possibly have imagined all
those years ago when I was here at Yale
but how is it really in terms of
acceptance by the non-disabled peers
that you have it yell is it possible for
example for someone in a wheelchair to
be a member of one of the thinking
groups or on the stage at Yale Drama how
easy is it to form those personal
relationships to students with
disabilities date at Yale just in terms
of general acceptance could you give us
some kind of a picture yeah so not to
pull on specific names but the defy vice
president and treasurer are currently
dating each other so I think you both
are the new due date on this campus but
more broadly speaking everyone in defy
is involved with a lot of other groups
on campus in fact the vice president and
treasurer of defy are involved in a
production of The Rocky Horror Picture
Show I think in two days and so they're
going to be on the stage involved in
that and our treasurer is going to be
wearing a corset our treasurer is a dude
by the way just throwing that out there
so the people in défi at the very least
I know are very involved in lots of
student groups you've got you know
someone who's a knock
hello on campus we've got you know a
wide range of representation across the
different student groups that exist
music arts there's athletic involvement
we have some club athletes so people are
really getting involved on this campus
you know regardless of whether they have
a disability or not and it seems that
student groups are generally very
supportive of having students with
disabilities in those groups so I think
the culture on campus is a lack of
knowledge but a general willingness to
support it sounds like one of the
characteristics of Yale students
everywhere so thank you for sharing that
and here's the shout-out to true love at
Yale my husband and I he was davenport
class of 78 or married now 38 years so
there there is possibility for life and
marriage after Yale even all those years
ago I want to switch back to Jim for
just a moment Jim you in the class of 70
me class of 78 we're kind of rising
seniors in that very large perspective
of the journey of life what do you see
as a potential for some of us who have
had a lot of experience in this
community in providing expertise or just
association with the Yale community here
on campus or throughout the nation
that's a funny question for me I never
took a history course in Yale I never
took an English course I never took an
art course I took all science and now
I'm 70 years old in history is suddenly
fascinating I
don't know what happened but my answer
is it's to provide that sense of what
came before history I got here in 66 and
I've been racking my brains for years I
can't think of anybody with any kind of
visible disability at Yale in 1966 and
yet of course mental illness was
underneath many of our experiences and
some of my friends wound up in bad
places because of it but we have a
history of Yale that goes back further
the American eugenics society from about
1870 to the 1930 the world was consumed
with eugenics as a leading belief in
social science eugenics from the Greek
meaning good birth was the idea the
people who are different people were a
lesser than the master race should be
eliminated from the gene pool entirely
that's huge Ennis the AES was on Elmen
Grove the headquarters was at Yale so
our history is long and grim and so
really I think those of us who have been
around a long time can tell a story of
tragedy and triumph because so much has
changed in our lifetime when I graduated
1970 we didn't have free appropriate
public education in American schools
that happened because of a lawsuit at
that same institution Penner's in 1971
called the right to education and it was
won because children who were not
allowed in public school were being sent
to institutions at roughly adolescence
the arc the Association then for
[ __ ] children to Pennsylvania filed
suit and won the right to education four
years later it was national law my
children went school with all kinds of
kids and teachers with disabilities and
it's made such a difference in automatic
acceptance and the feeling of big deal
that's I think where we want to get to
so that leads us back to both of our
Sarah's I think let's start first with
Sarah Scott Chang and your discussion
about the work and we know that it's
hard work that you do in order to ensure
that students with disabilities at Yale
have
opportunity equally with students who do
not have disabilities to engage and
choose their classes and really be fully
involved like any other student what
we're looking at towards that goal of
full inclusion what would you say we
need to do on Yale's campus in order to
get to that next step where inclusion is
a given where as as Paige has told us
it's easy for students with disabilities
to be in the broader community for
extracurricular activities but also in
terms of the core educational work that
goes on here classes studying
examinations could you talk a little bit
about that like like Paige said I think
that the people at Yale wants to do the
right thing I people want to be
inclusive people want to be on the right
side of history and sometimes they just
don't know how to do that there was an
amazing panel last week with Paige and a
number of her student colleagues on how
to build an inclusive classroom at Yale
it was great and they talked about as a
from a student's perspective what it
means to be going to class and have some
assignment or materials or whatever it
might be in your academic program that's
there but you can't quite access it
because of the way the professor is
presenting it because of the
requirements of the course and a lot of
that could be fixed if if there was less
of a concern of this is the way we do it
because this is the way we've done it
for the last 300 years and more of a
mindset of how can I make my course and
this information available and
accessible to the most number of
students in the most number of ways
because not everybody learns the same
way
and if the goal of a class is for
students to learn information and to
have mastery of that information there's
a lot of different ways that that can be
done so I would really love to see more
of an inclusion mindset across campus
especially in the faculty because I
think they are in a great position of
power and and can model that kind of
behavior for everyone
students also I think students are
naturally tend to be a little more
inclusive faculty staff everybody just
thinking about how can we make this
thing whether it's a class or a student
event or a talk like this more
accessible to more people so Sarah other
Sarah Sarah Bochy you've told us with
such great depth of feeling about the
frustration and the guilt and also the
cost involved in caring for a loved one
who is in the final stages of dealing
with a disability we know that this is
true throughout all of the stages for a
person who is challenged by disability
and I'm wondering if you could in your
capacity as a professional caregiver as
a physician talk a little bit about what
you think could be done in order to
ensure accessibility of medical care
both in terms of the availability of
physicians physicians with disabilities
and also the cost issues that we're
facing that's so I take care of pregnant
women and I have taken care of women
with spinal cord injuries who give birth
and there's unique considerations with
that in terms of I work in a hospital so
my hospital is completely accessible so
that's not been a challenge for me but
um men mentioned the the discussion we
had last night about the mammograms this
was actually something that was brought
on my radar because it's not something I
deal with but for example women when
they have mammograms have to be standing
and this is not having a mammogram
device that will accommodate a woman
is seated it's not readily available and
so this is the sort of thing that needs
to be on people's radar because just
because you're disabled doesn't mean you
can't get breast cancer so that would be
an example what was the power of your
question that was just hoping you might
also help us understand a little bit
about the cost this is a major
discussion raging across the nation
right now in terms of how we deal with
the availability and cost of healthcare
and perhaps you could share some of your
thoughts about best ways to wrap the
disability community in in a meaningful
way
everything's getting dismantled right
now it's terrible and I have patients
that are I mean I practice in Virginia
which is not Mississippi but I patients
that have lost insurance because of the
dismantling of Obamacare and so people
will choose you know they may I'll give
an example of a diabetic which isn't
necessarily a disabled person but
they'll ration their insulin that puts a
baby than at risk for a stillbirth so I
don't know what the solution is I feel
like that's way above my pay grade is
there a way I could address those
something he brought up with the
eugenics so in my capacity it's a
high-risk OBGYN I feel like almost what
you're saying what's old is new again
ACOG the American College of ob-gyn
mandates that we offer all pregnant
couples screening for a hundred and
eight genetic diseases and so if a
couple finds out that their child may
have this and additionally we're doing
18 week ultrasound to look to see if the
babies have birth defects the couples
are now faced with a difficult decision
and this disease our births that would
have happened a generation ago without
anybody knowing that they had a child
that might have a particular problem so
I definitely in the privacy of my
doctor's offices and seeing patients
make the decision to terminate children
that would be born with disabilities and
that's a really complicated topic it was
complicated for me with a husband who is
disabled that I love terribly but I have
to of course be it just provides support
for whatever decision
and be in compliance with the law but I
think there is a movement for any of you
that have been pregnant recently or have
people that are pregnant in your life
you may be aware that this is the
pendulums kind of switching a little bit
with the science advancing with all the
testing that we can do on fetuses so the
bioethics concern for people in the
disability community is something that
has really been prominent both in
situations like the one you're
describing where people are being
offered or forced to make choices about
welcoming someone with a disability into
the world and their family and also on
the broader topics that engage all of us
healthcare education transportation
housing perhaps most prominently in the
news the discussion about the ethics
around self-driving cars we know that
that would be of tremendous value to
someone like me who is blind I haven't
been able to drive since I was 26 years
old and yet there are ethical
considerations and push backs how these
algorithms work in terms of making a
decision about what happens if a
collision has to occur do you select to
have less impact to the car that has a
baby carrier or the back seat do you
decide that it's not so important if we
know that the driver is over the age of
well in deference to Jim and myself
might say 85 these are very important
issues that might Henri be the subject
of another discussion at the Yale
community or perhaps among the alumni to
talk about the ethics that are involved
in these very difficult decisions so we
want to go to some QA but before we do
that I'd like to engage with all of you
in what I like to think of as last round
rapid-fire answer so get ready with one
sentence or less as an answer to this
question I'm going to start with Paige
and just move right across the panel and
the question is this 2020 marks the 30th
anniversary of the passage of the
Americans with Disabilities Act
we literally have people sitting at this
table who lived most of their lives
before that became a law and then we
have Paige who has lived her entire life
the recipient of the benefits of that
law so next year in 2020 but then let's
just push it ten years out in one
sentence or less what do you want to see
as the most important focus for the
disability and engaged community going
forward in lieu of a more you know
complicated answer I would say a really
important element of the disability
conversation going forward you know so
in ten years from now I would really
love to see the focus of the disability
community shifting from receiving
accommodations to okay everyone's
accommodated the next step is building
better community and making it so people
aren't afraid of disability and being
disabled and this also goes back to the
eugenics conversation not being afraid
to have a disabled child for example
like they are today even with the
existing accommodations it's still so
stigmatized that people are afraid of
disability Sara so my answer is kind of
similar to pages in that I would like to
see a world where my office didn't need
to exist where we didn't need to make
accommodations because everything was
Universal Design and an accommodations
weren't needed because everyone could
access everything at any time might be a
few more than 10 years from now on
September 6 2018 the New York Times
published an article an op-ed by five
high school students called it's time
for a national museum on disabilities I
give us ten years and Sarah this is real
simple don't Park in my handicap spot
when I got the van I echo that sentiment
so you know as moderator I just want to
first of all thank all of our panelists
for being just really both attentive to
the topic of conversation and for
sharing your insight I want to answer my
own question in one word in 10 years I I
want to see us as fully included and I
mean fully included so don't tell me you
know my dog in your restaurant don't
kick me out of your Oberer don't tell me
that I can't be part of a book club even
though I can no longer read and I'm
technically illiterate just let us in so
with that I'm gonna ask Henry to come
back and steal my microphone again so
that we can take some kinds of questions
that was super I'm Richard Kane med
school 76 I'm curious about the
educational piece at Yale we have Dean
Chun here as well perhaps I'm just
wondering if there is some room in the
curriculum in orientation at the med
school are now looking at putting
disability into the curriculum there's a
tiniest snippet in orientation as a
physician I was never taught anything
about disability I merely acquired it by
one-on-one experience even how to deal
with people in wheelchairs there's
literally no teaching in yell net school
at this point so that educational piece
I think would be really important not
only in the medical school but across
all of the university and I would love
to see that opportunity to be developed
well I can speak to what we do for
education I am that little bit of
education at the med school right now I
spend the summer going out to all the
different programs orienting the new
students talking about our office and
what we do reminding the medical
students that the disability exists but
I can't I can't provide the curriculum
for them and I agree that that is
something that it would be really great
because this is something that as
healthcare practitioners they're going
to be dealing with probably every day of
their lives so we have have worked on
increasing our kind of community
outreach and and getting students as
they come in the door to tell them who
we are and what we do and not to forget
that we exist but I think there's a lot
of room for growth I also want to add
from an undergraduate perspective so not
necessarily a medical school perspective
but in terms of you know finding areas
and ways in which to learn about
disability I found that I've had to
create the curriculum myself within
existing classes so as a history major
studying history of disabilities I've
taken classes on a random ancient
civilizations where you know the the
whole seminar leads up to this term
paper on whatever topic you choose
within the field of study and I make
that topic paper about disability in
that ancient civilization or whatever it
is I try to apply it and I have to
actively you know teach myself do that
own research write the paper myself and
create that disability education that I
would like to have but I have found you
know every year there's usually one or
two courses often in the psychology
department that talk about working with
children with disabilities and I think
that's about the extent of the
undergraduate curriculum that is
generally provided there's also history
of science history of medicine in public
health so H s H M as a department
occasionally talks more to disability or
mentions
in one week of the entire class and so
there are small areas of opportunity
where if you are really looking for it
you can find it once per semester one
week per semester but there is no
overarching curriculum or waiver
students not interested in disability to
be exposed to it in an academic context
which i think is also very important for
normalizing disability so Paige Sarah
just to follow that up do you think that
it would be reasonable to envision a day
where there is a major disability rights
and advocacy the way we've developed
majors for American Studies so I'll jump
in really quickly and saying that one of
the five long-term goals is to get some
sort of disability studies program at U
it's a very long-term goal I know right
now with ethnicity race and migration
that's been just a whole other topic
about you know getting that approved as
a field of study and getting hiring
power for the faculty and you know we
would like altima to have something
similar where disability studies has
like one or two faculty members over
time even more and that students can
study it studying the history of
disability advocacy things like that not
just studying in a medical context as
you know disabled bodies to be studied
from the medical perspective but as
disabled individuals to understand to
learn about to learn the history of and
I think that's one of our ultimate goals
so I would like to see some sort of not
necessarily major but a program of study
here at Yale I completely agree with
Paige I think that it would go really
really far toward building community and
and building that inclusive tenure from
no world where disability is just
another facet of life and just another
identity that people can have your
question was whether it's reasonable I'm
not sure
I love that but I think it would be a
great thing to reasonability already
we're seeing some support from certain
departments here at Yale like women in
gender and sexuality studies WGS s has
been pretty supportive and willing to
potentially include some disability
studies in their curriculum so that
would be you know an avenue for us to
pursue would be starting out by having
disability studies offered within a
larger studies program and then
eventually branching off into its what
is it
[Music]
[Music]
he operates doing ob/gyn surgery using a
lift and they have created a way for him
to do his practice despite his
disability I've had classmates with
minor disabilities but I've also seen
people at the school who have more
significant disability and the hope is
that they can continue to practice and
have the school accommodate have the
patients accommodate I think when you
have a caregiver in a wheelchair there's
often a transfer where people think that
the doctor has a bigger problem than the
patient does and you really have to
negotiate that I think that we have a
lot to learn and you know I'm excited
that that we're talking about that today
my husband worked for and he had a cane
like you did for most of his working
career as an oncologist and he switched
from surgery to UM
radiation oncology because you didn't
have the dexterity but he worked for six
months in an electric wheelchair at my
hospital and I would go empty his Foley
and give him his meds but his cancer
patients were so receptive to him I mean
I think it was because they were
end-of-life patients themselves it was
beautiful and then he got too sick to do
it anymore but he did not lose his
practice in a quadriplegic and yet
escribe yeah very courageous and thank
you all so much Sarah I love what you
said about sort of making your office
obsolete and I'm curious if part of that
is teaching students the self-advocacy
skills to kind of know what they need
and ask for it and how to do that yeah
definitely I think that that that can be
a really big hurdle for students to get
over when they first come is the first
year because the laws that apply in the
K through 12 world are very different
than the laws that apply in higher ed
and they go through K through 12 with
their parents and their teachers and
administrators just all knowing what the
disability is knowing what the
accommodations are and everything just
kind of happening for them almost
magically and then they get here and
cross some invisible line that they
never knew existed and then suddenly
they have to advocate for themselves and
they're in our office crying because
they have no idea how any of this works
so we try to first off be very patient
and sympathetic and understanding what
students when they first get here
because it's a lot to suddenly have to
advocate for yourself especially if
you've never done it before it's
intimidating it's daunting I had a
student break down and cry one time when
she understood that she needed to tell
her faculty that she used accommodations
and she just started crying and said but
he's a Nobel Prize winner how can I
possibly have that conversation with him
so I think that is tough and then
especially in the realm of invisible
disabilities there can be an extra layer
of difficulty there because if you're
having conversations with people and
they can't see and understand that
you're a person with a disability and
they just kind of have to take your word
for it
some people have a hard time with that
and and they really grapple with you
know why why why is bipolar why would
that be a disability
can't you just toughen up and get over
it so being a self-advocate in the face
of that can be really hard for anyone
and especially a young person who's also
trying to come to college and learn all
the other things that 18 year-olds are
learning so I do think self-advocacy is
really important but I also think that
all the onus shouldn't be put on the
student to do that right there needs to
also be kind of a culture change in the
community at large that's more accepting
of those things the more understanding
of things even if they can't see it
hi I was wondering what percentage of
the undergraduate population and you
know the other schools as well
currently identifies as a person with
disability both physical or mental
health problems and would you consider
that you are an underserved or under not
underserved necessary but
underrepresented minority at Yale and
the point that you made about it being a
place of perfection is that something
that prevents many students who could
contribute here from even arriving on
campus and contributing in various ways
so we have about 10 percent of the
student population registered with our
office I don't really know the breakdown
for undergrad versus all the
professional schools off the top of my
head my sense is that it's about the
same across all the schools that 10% is
students who have a lifetime disability
students who are new to a diagnosis like
Paige was her first year students who
got a concussion a couple weeks ago and
are just dealing with that for the rest
of this semester so it's a really wide
range of things some use accommodations
throughout their entire time here some
students use it just for a kind of
finite period of time as they're
recovering we have students that have
situations that are sporadic and they
might be heavy users of accommodations
one semester and then not not want
anything to do with us for the next year
but generally about 10% of the student
population I do think we are under
resourced in this sense that there's a
lot of other work that we could do as it
is where we're we're making
accommodations for things that come up
right so a student's in a class and they
have some material that they can't
access so we're working to make it so
that they can access that reading if we
had more resources we could do more
front-end work and and work directly
with the faculty and make sure that all
materials are going to be digitally
accessible for all classes moving
forward so then we don't have to do
those
nations case-by-case basis I think I'm
trying to put our office out of work a
number of times but I do think that
there's a lot of room for that kind of
extra resources could help us do that
work better and then also kind of to
what Paige has talked about there's a
lot of community building that needs to
happen our office is kind of more for
compliance so I'm not sure exactly where
the right fit is for that but I do think
there's a real need for an a value in
building a community at the University
generally and there's a lot of room for
growth there mental health and mental
illness we all know that suicide is a
crisis situation and all campuses across
the nation and around the world and I
have heard tell some peer support groups
hearing at other universities would you
like to comment on what your department
does in terms of helping students in
that crisis so we're not mental health
clinicians and we like to make that very
clear right we are not the kind of first
stop if you're in a crisis then we will
help you get to the right people we'll
help you get connected with student
mental health but that's not what what
we ought to be doing we do are by far
our fastest-growing kind of percentage
of students is students that identify
with mental health concerns and we are
continually working on building the
community and the relationship with
student mental health there's a number
of student groups Paige would probably
be better equipped to talk about this
student groups that work on issues
around mental health and peer counseling
and and just kind of raising awareness
about mental health on campus generally
and I think that's really important work
also yeah so before I talk about mental
health I want to touch briefly on the
original question I just want to add
that
everyone who identifies with a
disability or who requires
accommodations goes to student
accessibility services a couple of even
my peer mentees alone not even just like
looking at the whole program but just
the ones who are my mentees have not
been registered with student
accessibility services and I've you know
suggested that they register and seek
accommodations but not everyone with the
disability on this campus does so that
10% number it's probably much higher in
reality in terms of how many students
need some form of accommodation have
some form of disability I would also add
that we also feel like student
accessibility services does not have
enough resources and we feel that as a
community we are underrepresented on
this campus in terms of you know
professor's hearing our voices student
groups having our involvement or
requesting our involvement or even
taking into consideration the
accessibility of the location of an
event we put a section in the guide for
navigating disability at Yale that talks
about social life on campus and you know
our Secretary of events aria she's
fantastic
she is in a wheelchair and she was
talking about the accessibility of
different frats only one frat on this
campus is wheelchair accessible for
example and the fact that that you know
came into conversation in our group is
just very interesting that you know none
of these fraternities sororities have
thought about accessibility of their
locations a lot of these social groups
that occur off campus a lot of the
events that occur off campus are not in
accessible locations and just the lack
of involvement and requesting of
disabled voices in some of those areas
has made it so we can't even enter those
spaces so I think that you know we're
generally our voices are
underrepresented in certain sections of
the student population not across the
board but there are certain areas where
you know the community could do better
in terms of listening to us and having
us involved and then to the point about
mental health
we as défi have partner with a couple
mental health groups on campus so the
Yale layer is a publication
deals with mental health and mental
illness on this campus and we have
worked with them we've gotten involved a
little bit with formerly known as
mindmatters I don't know what their new
name is but they're a group that
promotes mental well-being on campus you
know we've worked some we reached out to
the Walden peer counselors they do peer
counseling for students with mental
illness and we've tried in general to be
more inclusive of students with mental
illness so the peer mentor program did a
bunch of outreach to get students with
mental illness more involved and we do
have quite a few mentees whose diagnoses
are you know mental health related so
that is a huge and growing part of our
undergraduate advocacy community as well
as those of mental illness hi my name is
Mary I'm a rehabilitation physician by
training but Yale School of Public
Health three years ago I think this was
an excellent seminar today and really
appreciate the candidness of all of our
of our moderator and all of our speakers
so thank you very much for that I think
this is a great start I think this is
opening up the conversation here in the
Yale community I think in the state of
Connecticut and even nationally we can
do so much more
mentioning that next year is the 30th
anniversary of the ADA a you know
perfect opportunity I think for Yale
through cross school collaboration to
have a longer seminar to talk about
these issues so I'll throw that out
there for I would love to participate in
that by the way I work in New Haven now
not for Yale but I think it's an
opportunity thank you
hi good afternoon thank you so much for
that that discussion it was fantastic I
like my neighbor was really impressed by
what you said Sara about you know a
world where your office is not needed
and so when I think about DS
stigmatizing disability one of the major
opportunities I see as a rehabilitation
physician is recreation and sports I
think there's very few things that are
more galvanizing cohesive and completely
empowering and so I was just wondering
in your office how many students who
have disabilities or who identifies
having a disability come to you looking
for recreation opportunities on campus
and what are those opportunities and if
there aren't that many how do you think
that might change and this can go to
either Paige or Sarah so that's an
interesting question because in the last
year or so I think we've seen that
coming up more and more and more I think
you're the biggest way that my office
interacts with student athletes is after
an injury we have met the entire women's
rugby team so you know I think that that
there's a good awareness of what we do
generally in the student athlete
community we've gotten like questions
recently about the accessibility of the
pool at Payne Whitney and and things
like that I've recently been opening up
connections with administrators in in
the gym to work on issues about
accessibility I think that there's a lot
of room for growth but like so many
other things there is definitely all the
attitudinal pieces are in place it's
just kind of figuring out how do we make
everything as accessible as it can be
Paige might have more information from a
student perspective though honestly not
really I've you know I've noticed a lot
of students are trying to get more
involved especially intramurals because
they're they're competitive but less so
that's sort of like a team bonding
experience in your residential college
and I think that that creates more
community cohesion which then makes
students with various disabilities more
likely to pursue intramurals as a
welcoming space I've also noticed that
you know some club sports like there's
clubs swimming and things like that are
probably more accessible but I haven't
seen individuals going those routes so
for the last two years I was on a club
sport I was on the climbing team and I
would love to see something like
adaptive climbing because I know that it
exists and I would love it if we could
bring it to this campus I think there
are a lot of opportunities for
improvement in that regard and since
there are so many club and intramural
sports I think there's a lot of
different ways in which this campus
could have more inclusive opportunities
for students with disabilities to
partake in recreational activities
[Music]
with the message from my mentor
professor John Wharton Blum who maybe is
as famous for his cameo on the Woody
Allen movie Zelig as he was for his
history courses in 20th century American
history when he said above all think act
be in the active tense thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]